this feels like it's sort of only legal
on the internet that's funny wow
hello you lot my name is Phil dunster
you guys are watching BuzzFeed nurse
tweets and it's about to get smutty all
up in here I'm feeling excited to
venture into the deep dark corners of
the web
okay number one Phil dunster
if you ever see this if I could give you
the Moon
I'd give you the moon I'm not sure what
I'd do with the moon unless they're
saying like the Moon is in like Moon me
and show their bottom which
I'm okay with Phil dunster has no
business being this cute he's like a
little ray of sunshine and then an emoji
that goes like
where is Phil dunster I want to kiss him
I'm right here Twitter user I'm right
here Phil dunster is so baby girl it's
insane what is that I don't know what
baby girl means I I have seen this
before and I'm I think I'm flattered
does it mean cute is it like is it that
is that that's less thirsty and more
like nourishing I think Phil dunster be
my boyfriend challenge what does that
mean also I mean this is this is just
goes to show how non-genzy I am there's
no capitals in this or punctuation and
so I am just immediately off the bat
confused is that like being my boyfriend
challenge like I challenge you to do it
or is that an actual challenge Jamie
tart is my baby boy my sweet little
angel and no one is allowed to ever hurt
him well
speak to Man City about that because
they get all up in his in his business
the way Phil dunster says Keely is
incredible and hot I mean the way I say
Keely is probably quite dull I think the
way that Jamie tart says Keila is
probably what they are referring to
incredible and hot incredibly hot no but
incredible and hot okay so when are we
getting a rom-com starring Phil dunster
and Brett Goldstein my God is season
three not enough for you is that not
rom-com enough I feel like most sort of
phone calls that Brett and I have are
mini rom-coms in themselves
less calm more ROM Phil dunster know how
to be hot if it's a a directive it says
I've got a lot to learn but I appreciate
the sentiment but again there is no
capital letters so I I do I do wonder is
is that is that a thing of people doing
that on purpose that they're not
actually do you have to go and cancel it
and then make it lowercase that's effort
man give Phil Dunst to an Emmy because
why am I as a lesbian having to pause
this show to giggle and kick my feet
about Jamie Tarts I don't know if I can
be the one to answer this um as a mostly
straight white dude but
um I I I I don't know if giggling and
kicking your feet about a fictional
character is enough to perhaps turn your
sexuality I don't know I don't want to
be the one to tell you random Twitter
user but it's a very cute image Phil
dance to dancing
baby let me talk to you
he didn't let me talk to you I don't
know what the Emoji is oh it's hot Emoji
can you see that
it looks a bit like there's horns maybe
it's horny when Phil dunster goes I lose
a part of my soul for real quite
pleasing myself I knew that FR means for
real he gets his tongue out quite a lot
doesn't he Jamie and uh that's the end
of that sentence Jamie tart the juicy
butt there's a sort of lack of
description around a lot of it and I
quite like that sort of deconstructed
sentences you could say in many
different ways Jamie tart the juicy butt
Jamie tart the juicy butt I'm going to
take some credit for the juicy butt it's
not all Jamie tart it's a little bit
filled under okay now this does have an
initialism or an abbreviation that I
don't know but I'm going to give it a go
Theodore dance defines Fook idec I don't
even care
ah Phil dance to find his Fook I don't
again no capital what's going on who's
got that much time to go back and do it
I know that's not the point of this but
you know grammar is what gets me hot
under the collar Jamie tart is so sexy I
need to speak my truth you've spoken it
and I appreciate it it's Jackie Levy who
is in charge of costume and she puts him
in some pretty
pretty naughty clubber as they call it
this is another challenge I feel like
we've stepped up again with this one
Jamie tart and Roy Kent rail each other
then me challenge
rail each other it's such a it's such an
image isn't it let's just take a moment
yeah yeah oh sore feels like things are
sore okay there's an emoji at the end of
this one I'd let Phil dunster feel me
like a dumpster this feels like it's
sort of only legal on the internet I'd
let Phil dunster pee on me just saying I
don't know how to say this but I I feel
like that might be a step too far in in
the relationship that we have random
Twitter user if we maybe get to know
each other I don't know and you buy me a
drink or a few drinks I need to be quite
well hydrated for that blonde Phil
dunster could kill me and my ghost would
say thank you baby
again there's a lot of sort of Sado
masochism here what the [__] is Jamie
tart so sexy for like what do you want
from me to kneel to bend over say it I
want you to be happy random Twitter user
and if it means you kneeling or bending
over then please do it Jamie tart could
break my heart and my back punch me in
the face run over me with his 500 000
sports car and spit in my mouth and I
would totally let him and then I would
kiss the ground He Walked on wow there's
a lot of pain with this it's not just
like I'd like him to take me out for it
for a date uh hold my hand as we walk
home tell me I look beautiful I wouldn't
run you over wouldn't punch you I might
split in your mouth I don't really know
it depends if the moment takes me I
certainly wouldn't break your heart
I'd hold your hand and I'd make you feel
secure and warm well guys I've been Phil
dunster you've been thirsty AF and I've
had a great time if you've been watching
this and been like who the hell is this
guy I understand but if you go and watch
Ted lasso on Apple TV plus you might
have a better idea cheers then bye
[Music]
foreign